hey guys Dennis here the founder think
here I'm David Griffin your resident
comic book and video game guru and this
is our 2013 end of the year top 5
television shows yes and we're not
really gonna order them in it we're not
going 1 through 5 or anything like that
we were just saying what our top 5 are
there's some that that we both have on
our list and then there's others that
only one of us has on their list I think
doing TV this year and I think will be
next year even it's harder than doing
movies there's so many there's so many
good TV there's TV series what kind of I
mean we're not even gonna mention on the
mini series I mean there's there's too
much TV out right now so much TV all
right now all right well let's start off
with this one this is you one of your
top 5 picks sleeping on my top 5 picks
one of the best new shows I think of the
fall fall 2013 it's it's a show that at
first thought was gonna be a cop
procedural disguises let's say like CW
show super national you know huge cult
fun with that it is that but it's it's
so fun and they have so much mythology
they build on each week each week is an
exciting new episode and there's always
something new to learn and I love Fox's
decision this did get renewed for a
second season they thought about maybe
bumping up to 22 episodes but I said you
know what we're gonna make this season
13 episodes in a new next season season
2 13 episodes as well I prefer that I
love it that way so keeps a story tight
I mean there's always something
happening Tom Mison me so I'm gonna say
his name are missing it's like he's like
probably the one of the breakthrough
performers of this year's you go as you
keep progression to the series you'll
see like he's such a good actor he
steals every scene he's in it's just
it's just so well done I think it's fun
great cast - cool I've only seen the
pilot I enjoyed it but I haven't watched
it enough to say okay this is one of my
favorite shows on TV those kind of
bonkers a little bit it's not straight
for like you know I you know I've kind
of talked about almost human almost
being too safe this show doesn't play
it's a let's show actually sometimes
just some weird things I'm like really
they're getting away with that way they
did some weird stuff and that's why I
like I feel like much about it alright
so next one is justified this is in my
top five
not in David's is it in your top 10
maybe my top 10 yeah okay
justified this season wasn't as strong
season three or season two which was my
favorite however it's still great you
know great dialogue great characters the
only issue I had with this season was
that it wasn't quite as focused his
previous season they had a big story in
this in season four but it kind of
meandered sometimes there was there was
like they would take an episode off and
do something that would never come back
around again like for example the
epilepsy where where the girl bounty
hunter all right he has a go chase down
the guy and and they kind of never
really Wow wound that really back also
the main story wasn't as interesting as
mystery about who fell from the sky yes
we even found out I'm like so even
though though I say those things it's
still one of the best shows on
television well-written yeah you know
the dialogue Timothy Olyphant he's great
as Raylan that's great
Walton Goggins is Boyd one of the best
villains oh yeah on television today so
yeah I still highly recommend it and
maybe season 5 will we'll get back on
track yeah I hope so
okay and the next one is one of your
picks era CW's arrow has been really
surprised
CW you know as some hits or misses you
wha know in there I got a little
whatever but I mean you know that it
this show it hit the mark you know you
know I'm a Vampire Diaries fan originals
I think is overtaking that right now is
the better show and then arrow came out
last year and it it surprised me I was
like okay we'll see I would never got
into Smallville I just couldn't do it
I heard the first couple seasons are
good yeah I enjoyed the first like three
four seasons of Smallville right and
then this came out and I'm like wow this
is really good small they keep it small
it knows what kind of show it is I mean
it's basically he's Batman he's Bruce
Wayne I mean he has a really deep raspy
voice but it's so good the thing is
because DC's Cinematic Universe is a
complete mess they can do whatever they
want I mean in the new season well they
got flash in their flash coming now
they're the midseason finale had flash
we got we got Black Canary we got
Deathstroke played by men yuba Nev from
Spartacus I mean
this is this go bonkers with this show
because they can there's no movie
universe holding them back so this is a
definitely show I would suggest watching
it's on Netflix right now you can stream
the first season catch up to season two
yeah I've only seen episode and half of
it I liked it so far I just need to
watch more to see like if I can get into
it or not
definitely definitely my favorites
alright the next one this is in my top
five house of cards is this anywhere in
your top ten I would put a yeah put top
ten top ten because of the performances
yeah yeah open the top ten I think when
this came out there's a lot of hype
about how Netflix is gonna like
revolutionize things and this show for
me
I thought the formula was pretty
episodic it's pretty basic you know for
this universe I mean there was an
overall story but it was just kind of a
basic format but the content within
those episodes is strong those that cast
is crazy
yeah I mean the whole Netflix model of
binge watching and getting people to
watch all of them all at the same time
you know I thought it was great I think
it's it's definitely the right step in
the right direction
for television in general you know at
least in my viewing habits I liked it
I'd like to binge watch I like to watch
even you know a show we're gonna talk
about later Game of Thrones I loved the
show watching it week to week is not as
good as watching it all together
building for me though with the whole
binge watching which I do I'm guilty of
I'd do it I the week to week
conversation though it's harder for you
and I to review it when it's all at once
cuz like what do we talk about it's I
gotta talk about the whole thing right
where's Game of Thrones you kind of have
that week talking about it and
conversing Twitter you know tweeting and
then then it hits the next week so I
mean there's yeah yeah yeah so I thought
it was yeah great performances great
political thriller what's great about of
to is like it's it doesn't really have a
political side to it it's talking about
the kind of the corrupt nature of
politics in general and how you know how
seedy it is and how back dealing all
right yeah it doesn't really say who
Democrats are better Republicans are
better it's it's basically saying this
is how this is how things get done in
Washington and it's not fair
no not very clean not very corrupt yeah
and I think my favorite even though
Kevin Spacey of course is obvious but I
think Robin right like yeah she's
awesome yeah okay tomorrow's good
tomorrow's good yeah she's stepping up I
mean she's becoming just as popular as
Rooney if not more so now yeah yeah all
right and so speaking of the Netflix
model this is in yours hop this was my
top five orange is the new black I love
this I wasn't no to expect I just heard
there's no kind of growth you just like
just people just talking about yeah it
was strictly online buzz it's it's weird
because I've seen got more views than
house of cards yes the there's more
hours watched of orange is the new black
then there is house of cards right and
this had like hardly any advert no house
of cards was everywhere see billboards
basic commercials blah blah blah because
it had the names yeah this didn't really
have like big names in it I think Jason
Biggs is probably the you know Jason
Biggs and what's her name laura Prepon
yeah perfect from a 70 show and then
what's her name hon even recognized from
Star Trek Voyager Oh Kate Mulgrew yeah
yeah captain there's Captain Janeway
herself I mean this show and I love
about it so much that it features pretty
much majority all female yes and they
just own it I mean they own their roles
the comedy is great that it's got that
comedy and drama and it's long it's like
it reminds a lot of shameless oh it's
like 50 52 minutes 54 minutes per
episode and you think that might and I
hate this because when it's gonna get
categorized at the Emmys I'm assuming
it'll probably be more along the lines
of like how do you come it's not a
comedy it's like girl it's both though
it's comedy and it's both yeah so this
actually is in my top 10 and he almost
was in my top five you know I was
debating house of cards oranges new
black house car you know decided to go
with house of cars we left me wanting
more I think they both want you know but
I this was a pleasant surprise
all word of mouth I think it's fantastic
that you have female like emotion female
cast you know and so I'm really looking
forward to it as well it's in that
Netflix model of yeah you know they gave
you all the episodes you watched as many
as you wanted not yeah I think I fit in
the weekend yes yeah so alright into the
next one this is on my top five list
Boardwalk Empire there's a show you and
me
you know this is a show that actually is
better if you binge watch it which but
if you do that you actually have to wait
till the whole season is done hmm I
don't think this season was quite as
strong as last season's right especially
because of the ending the ending of this
season's kind of left you
yeah there's a little unsatisfied I
don't really feel there were you know
some major things that have been major
deaths yeah
but they left a lot of things unanswered
where last season the season finale I
was like okay that finale so but it's
still one of the best shows on
television great acting great writing
Terence winter who also wrote the Soviet
403 yeah I just I just love this show I
I've always enjoyed the show it's never
been like I've never loved it even
though I've really enjoyed that watched
every season I'm gonna can't wait for
the next season I just never I've never
loved it
it's a gorgeous show it's I think it
costs more per episode than Game of
Thrones it's like seven and a half
million per episode some ridiculous
assess I mean it looks like a movie like
it looks like a movie it's so well done
such good characters I mean great actors
you know of course um Michael Shannon no
Kenneth Williams did a great job Jeffrey
Wright as a guest star this season every
year always great guest stars even Ron
Livingston from office space and from
Band of Brothers was in it I mean just
just great casting where does it is in
your top 10 or top 20 top 10 I'm putting
my top 10 yeah it's not my top 5
definitely top down there okay all right
in the next show ah this is a show that
we both have in our list Breaking Bad we
a little fire on this show for not
getting fired up enough about this yeah
it's a final season it's over it's done
way through you know we get a lot of
flack because I really like the show you
know it's it's great you know Green's
not my favorite show of all time though
yeah I guess what people were upset yes
people gave us a lot of a lot of crap
right because it wasn't our favorite
show of all time yeah it's not my
favorite show of all no but I think it's
fantastic it's very good great
performance is it ended very good
you know in a very you know satisfying
way yeah the Bryan Cranston Aaron Paul
will deliver you know even the
supporting characters Gus fring might be
one of my favorite villains of any TV
show he's he was he was great he's an
awesome villain yeah so it ended on a
great note I had you know I so I think
it went out well yeah it was a good good
ending top five of the year top five of
the year just not my favorite show of
all time the top five of the year for
sure and so to our final pick of our top
fives that we both have on our list the
game of Thrones
yeah a third season exciting some huge
events like that right away twitter
breaking events yeah huge yeah this is
one of my favorite shows a it moves a
little faster than something like a
Boardwalk Empire though it still
benefits from a binge watching type of
yeah they're basically watched like a 10
hour movie so I mean it's just yeah I
mean you have to get the whole story and
it's not always gonna be like an
episodes gonna end neatly you know I
mean it's it's it's something that's
best but you have to watch a
week-to-week because you can't wait yeah
there's so many characters and plots
that are going on and nuanced stuff and
you just want to like sometimes one of
the worst things about watching the
episode is like oh we didn't get to see
so-and-so this week you know did it but
when you bend you watch it you get a see
it all but we just can't wait yeah I
think it's one of the best shows on
television hmm I think you know
sometimes some people over overlook it
because they like oh it's too slow or
you know I
some people are wrong with the sex on
the show I mean they they cut down the
sex position I think that's a little
ridiculous his name like you know just I
think they say they slowed it down
sufficient angular ridiculous like when
they said people having sex and it's
like speaking over the moment my father
was more it's just like really but I
mean they toned it down I mean you know
it's HBO it's premium network come on
yeah you gotta get something for your
$15 a month but yeah this is one of my
fav you this show all right and we
always get a lot of comments and a lot
of fans for the show it means now it's
grown to be
I think this
biggest show on HBO of all time yeah
Nexus Sopranos yeah it surpassed
truebloods best numbers yeah and a true
yeah I think true Plus kind of going on
the way now it's the most legally
downloaded show on television right now
according to HBO they actually were
proud of that they're like look you know
people talk about the Showtime I talk
about it all yeah it's a great show I
can't wait till it comes back on
hopefully we got to see a teaser trailer
pretty soon yes please
all right and yeah so that's what we
thought this is our our top 5 TV shows
of the year let us know what you think
what are your top 5 top 10 are they
similar to ours or their other ones you
can post your comments below on the
website think Ericom or on YouTube our
YouTube channels think you're a pro make
sure you subscribe to that go something
tells us on Twitter uh tell us what your
top 5 shows where this year top 10 top
20 whatever the list is I find us on at
think here oh I'm at Griffin de and we
also have a Facebook page that's
facebook.com slash think your fans make
sure you like that page and help us out
by tweeting and facebooking or our
videos that help out a lot
[Music]
you
[Music]